hello freak bitches see I'm weird but I
even I like I like me but I think
alcohol I love fucking when I'm on
alcohol a lot of people don't like the
really alcohol you know people are
saying I can get you know whiskey dick
you know well if you get really fucked
up you can get whiskey dick but yeah
you'd have to drink a lot yeah I would
not I'd have to be not alive yeah you
know of course you have a glass of wine
absolutely perfect before for sure yeah
fuck yeah for sure I think I've been
down there too if you fight you start
the problem when you start drinking is
alcohol reduces inhibitions alright it
removes your inhibitions and it removes
your inhibitions more with every drink
so you know if you're if you're a little
you know a little tipsy
you got like a little bit of inhibition
you ever throw up on a check no I did
right as I was about to eat her pussy
boy yeah hot chick I was 19
hey she was like we were drinking
greyhounds I'll never thought it was the
gray house or just what a greyhound is I
think it's gym its place a greyhound
it's it's light green light yellow I'm
not sure what the alcohol edges of the
berries it's grapefruit juice and vodka
or something like that I think it's
great food juice and vodka anyways it
was a greyhound whatever the fuck it is
I'm not a bartender so man I couldn't
believe I was getting this piece of
super hot open legs and right all I
remember is I threw up grab me she
grabbed me they dragged me down the
hallway and I just remember scenes of
going through the hallway throwing up
down the hallway and they're trying to
get me to the toilet I finally get to
the toilet I have a couple more yaks
left
please never I've never fucked never saw
her again other never saw yeah when I
was there's no way you can come back
from that you can fuck the throw-up into
her when I was young and use that Lube
on her ass when I was crying care it in
there what take the carrot out fucking
retarded I think you burn yourself
probably burn your neck it stomach in
your soul sir what do you bile burns on
your dick
man nobody ain't throwing up on your
dick try to fuck your girl in her house
yeah blow up you threw up in her and
then just said it's all slippery down
there let me just start yeah I might be
good at gunnery and shit maybe we're
really good hos over I fell asleep balls
going down on my girlfriend once at
least once when I used to have my paper
route yeah that's quite common but I
didn't fall so because I was tired
because I fucking through papers all day
I got drunk and I partied all night you
just get home and pull down your pants
and just fall asleep or something she
goes to the bathroom and you're just
wait and then you're done she comes back
and you're snoring
[Applause]
[Music]